you want to export your product to the web
but you are not sure what rules to follow
in that case
the test is the perfect tool for
you here you will find everything
you need to know about the rules and
regulations as well as the
customs duties you will have to pay let's say  you
want to export cocoa butter
from ghana to france firstly
choose the country of origin of your product
next choose the destination country
now you will need to find the
product code from the web for the
cocoa butter just click on
find my product code
then type cocoa butter in the
search box once you have
your product code click
search
now you can see all the information
about exporting cocoa butter
to water organized in tabs first
Here are the import procedures, the
customs procedures that you will have to
follow, for example, the documents that you
will have to fill in secondly, the
requirements applicable to the products,
here you will find the technical,
health and safety standards and the
labeling standards applicable to your product.
below are the tariffs here you
can see the duty you will have to
pay in customs when you export your
product to the web and the discounts
that you may be able to benefit from you
can also see all the taxes
applicable to your product in the
eu country at  that you plan to export it
since these will affect its final price
the rules of origin help us
define the economic nationality of your
product an important aspect to
claim the discount of rights
and finally you will also find the
volume of current imports of
your product in  the web and the origin of the
same information that you may need
for your business plan
with great test and a good product already
has everything you need to gain
a foothold in the largest market in the world
[Music]